ils veulent pas qu'on se mette tout nu
dans le bois ah non non
même c'est interdit moi ici mais moi je
m'en fous
c'est gentil
téléphone alors allô je suis au boulot
là tu me rappelles merci
bien gentil monsieur
c'est combien un ticket à peu près il va
me manquer un frangin un truc dans le
genre
important
non non ça coûte cher tu as donné
combien là
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est pour ça c'est plus rapide que
le portable de nos jours
et ça arrive au bout du monde
en plus je l'ai pas acheté hein
cours vite c'est tu le prends et tu
cours vite
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est forfait 300 francs
pas une petite pièce pour prendre mon
train s'il vous plaît
encore un petit tour un tout petit ça va
mieux ça va
Inez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais je veux bien oui
oh là là
au revoir
passe tu vas me m'emmener là-bas
[Musique]
tu vas me faire tomber c'est ça qui va
arriver enlève ta main pourquoi tu es
sympa jusque là quoi tu prenais quoi
sympa
tu peux attendre un petit peu le temps
que je monte je monte ça chez le futur
employeur monsieur reste avec toi
d'accord c'est possible
un téléphone
mais vous croyez qu'il va redescendre
assez rapidement et moi non mais pas
vous votre ami
la dernière
1 2 3 soleil ah tu bouges
je vais faire un tour
au revoir
ne il m'abandonne
[Musique]
sortez s'il vous plaît
alors on recommence remettez-vous là
on recommence allez-y bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir Nous sommes deux très bien c'est
pourquoi
c'est pas possible
ah d'accord c'est comme ça maintenant
je m'appelle Vincent enchanté
Olivier autrement ma mère travaille avec
Canal coco peut me faire rentrer je
il y en a d'autres bon c'est quoi le
numéro
[Musique]
vous êtes tout seul
bonjour bonjour monsieur
la défense on n'est pas arrivé
[Musique]
là je reviens j'ai mis deux heures
qui sont absolument
je peux vous proposer un truc en 10
minutes on peut y être
comme vous voulez moi faut qu'il soit
hyper rapide
[Musique]
pardon
ce mec il est fou ou quoi
ça ira plus vite
pour 22 francs
j'ai eu peur de vous le président
parce que j'étais un peu en retard moi
[Musique]
ça y est là on est hors contrôle radar
ok bah maintenant qu'on est tranquille
on va pouvoir procéder à l'échange
nous on a le pognon vous avez le
microphone
c'est quoi cette maladie là c'est
l'échange c'est les 100 briques vous
avez pas le paquet de clubs avec le
microfilm
Azar coffre
[Musique]
de passe aussi quel mot de passe j'avais
pas dit je veux à la défense
aujourd'hui ouais mais vous me l'avez
dit d'une façon qui m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille et je pensais que c'était vous
en plus on m'avait dit une veste
ringarde des lunettes Jean-Philippe
[Musique]
il y a c'est fortes chances annoncées
avec des vents de plus de 50 km heure
vous devez vous détourner tout de suite
sur Orléans mais non je peux pas là
maintenant tu peux pas
c'est tout oh merde qu'est-ce que
j'avais [__] à Orléans moi
vous voulez quand vous réserve un taxi à
Orléans ah non c'est bon pour le taxi
aujourd'hui ça va aller hein
[Musique]
on peut le déposer sur le parvis avec
l'échelle de corde ouais pas de problème
le sac on vous lancera ah non non il y a
des trucs
[Musique]
je vois pas pourquoi vous y arriverez
pas je suis pas belle bandeau moi alors
vous êtes bazarkov vous êtes pas
Belmondo
en tout cas vous avez fait un beau tour
d'hélicoptère bah ouais non mais c'est
surtout l'histoire
[Musique]
le
ticket non
parce que je lui dis ça parce que moi
j'en ai des pas cher c'est pour ça
oui ça se voit pas
bon là c'est parce que je suis pas bien
habillé parce qu'il fait chaud mais
sinon je suis contrôleur de l'autoroute
mais je vois pas trop le rapport
c'est que vous allez donner ce sticker
là au monsieur au péage là-bas et vous
allez payer 13 fois au lieu de payer 180
francs
parce que c'est moins loin
d'accord
vous pouvez me régler tout de suite
est-ce que j'ai l'air malhonnête est-ce
que j'ai l'air malhonnête
que c'est malin
j'ai des tickets pour le concert de Guy
Béart là sur l'aire de repos un peu plus
loin dans une demi-heure si vous
intéresse
et pour le prix je vous donne celui-là
aussi tiens
votre collègue celui-là
avant vous n'êtes pas du tout non pas du
tout ticket d'autoroute au fil
merci c'est moi qui vous remercie
et moi quand je vais passer vous pensez
qu'ils vont pas voir qui viennent plus
loin ça je sais pas faudra faire comme
si vous venez de pas très loin quoi
comme vous êtes un peu bronzé mettez une
crème blanche
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez des pétards
et des bisons 5 et les mitraillettes ça
pète bien là
et il faut il faut il faut le mettre
comment c'est pas dangereux c'est pas
dangereux
[Musique]
pourquoi
comme ça j'allume là
[Applaudissements]
non mais non défendu dans la rue il faut
pas faire ça ici non c'est ça claque
trop fort je lui dis il faut pas faire
ça là
il faut aller d'un espace qui est un
jardin
où il y a des enfants c'est mieux
non
on est bon 14 juillet c'est pas c'est
quand on est le combien là
c'est dommage on a le droit ça non
ça part pas
c'est lui c'est lui
un petit alors un tout petit juste un
tout petit un tout petit un tout petit
[Applaudissements]
reprenez les faut pas vendre ça c'est
pas bon c'est caca tenez je vous les
donne
je m'en vais
j'ai tout vu
j'ai tout vu comment quoi
et là tu dis quoi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout
ton cul
je tire de l'argent
c'est avec mon code
que je prends que je prends
une grosse mode
que je suis à la mode c'est qui
sa femme pour moi
celle-là tu la connais le curé de
Camaret aller
moi
appelle-moi
[Musique]
et appelle-moi
tu es parti loin
je t'ai rencontré
tu n'arrives pas
ouais merci
[Musique]
on prend que les billets nous parce que
les pièces ça donne les mains jaunes
oh tu es super sympa merci merci Brother
tiens tu vas faire l'amour avec fleurs
elle est toute fraîche
[Musique]
avec moi vous êtes très doué
tu ne réponds pas il y a personne à côté
de toi
et tu es
[Musique]
oh merde
c'est quoi Samsung c'est un livraison
pour les boules de Noël aux 46
vous avez des aspirateurs
je vais vous donner une pelle
je me suis fait mal en plus estimez-vous
heureux que je porte pas plein parce que
ça glisse là vous voulez porter plainte
en plus ça glisse
[Musique]
voici c'est bon c'est là ça fait de la
neige
[Musique]
bordel de merde non c'est pas comme ça
je fais quoi moi
les clients c'est le risque de se casser
quelque chose
regardez-moi ça en plus il y a plein de
cheveux
faut faire attention c'est hyper
dangereux
si vous plonge j'appelle la police
[Musique]
ici
dans le coin
pour la caméra cachée
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
ils veulent pas qu'on se mette tout nu
dans le bois
ah c'est interdit de se mettre tout nu
même si tard dis-moi ici mais moi je
m'en fous donc je peux me mettre tout nu
ici avec vous on craint rien
non non
donc je me mets un petit coup de rouge à
lèvres puis c'est bon non c'est un mec
c'est différent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mono ça passe encore mais n'importe
comment une femme à poil ou un gasi à
poil c'est clair c'est
exhibition sexuelle allez à tous ça
rigole pas la tête des collègues qui
vont là-bas
[Musique]